الانظار كلها متجهه نحو الدوحه لمتابعه
الحدث الاهم في واحه العلوم والتكنولوجيا
اربع نجوم ستلمع ابتكاراتها لتضيء مستقبل
العالم العربي
ما هي الا لحظات ويبدا حفل تخرج شيل
الثامن
نجوم العيون
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته حياكم
الله مشاهدينا الكرام عبر شاشه الام بي سي
4 وايضا عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي انا
خالد الجميلي وهذا هو نهائي الموسم الثامن
من نجوم العلوم برنامج اطلقته مؤسسه قطر
للتربيه والعلوم وتنميه المجتمع لاطلاق
القدرات والامكانيات العلميه لدى الشباب
بالعربي من هذه الليله الليله الحلم نختم
رحله علميه استمرت شهور في هذه الليله نجم
جديد سيضيء في سماء العلوم القلوب تدق على
وقع المنافسه وبساط ريح سيحمر المبدعين
الاربعه الى النجوميه على مدى اسبوع صوتهم
للمفضل لديكم لكن مصير المبدعين مرتبط
بتصويت لجنه التحكيم الجميع في الخارج
ينتظر النتيجه النهائيه خبراء وفائزون في
المواسم السابقه حضروا لدعم زملائهم
كلش حلوه في المكان
[تصفيق]
افكارنا لحد احنا ما نطلع منتجات هذه خمس
مره بكون بالفناني انا محمد
اشتغلوا شغل كتير حيكون صعب صعب اننا
نختار واحد من الثاني ان شاء الله
المشاركه مع شباب العربي في الموسم الثامن
من نجوم العلوم شكون الشباب
لما شفتوا صراحه ما صدقت حسيت اني صراحه
انا النجم
رايحين للنجوميه رايحين للعالميه
[تصفيق]
لما فتنا والناس كلها بتزقف شفت عالم
اشتغلت معهم الشعور بجنن انه التيم ورك
هلا اليوم واليوم راح يتحدد مصيره
انا كتير فرحان انه وصلت وان شاء الله
اكون الاول بس لو ما طلعت الاول اتمنى
لاخيك ما تتمنى على نفسك يعني
رح يطلع الاول وانا شخصيا يعني من الاول
عن جد مشروع ناجح
ركبه
[تصفيق]
وصلني كتير
[موسيقى]
انا صورت حق سديم مقديسات لان فعلا قصه
نجاح وبالنهايه قرار راح يكون حق لجنه
الحكم يختارون مخترع العرب لعام 2016
[موسيقى]
اظن انكم لاحظتم اننا نعيش عرسا علميا
ظهر واضحا على وجوه الجميع ولكن بدون شك
يبقى القلق والتوتر السيطرانيه على مبدعين
الاربعه ولا شيء غريب هي الادوار نفسها
تكررت عبر اسابيع المغامره العلميه التي
شهدت فرحا وحزنا وامومه ايضا لحظات لا
تنسى من الموسم الثامن بنجوم
[تصفيق]
منذ ثمان سنوات
انطلق الحلم حلم كبر عبر المواسم ليبلغ
اليوم سنته الثامنه
[موسيقى]
خرجوه حصدوا نجاحات كبيره كبرا العالم
حلم اسمه نجوم العيون لمس صحوه كل شاب
عربي طموح
حلم راعته مؤسسه قطر للتربيه والتعليم
والتنميه المجتمع
انا اكيد اتفرج على برنامج الموسم الثامن
وعايز اعرف ايه الاختراعات اللي هتكون مش
اركه
اليوم والى موسمه الثامن توافد المبتكرون
باعداد هائله لم يشهدها اي موسم من قبل
واحه العلوم والتكنولوجيا شرعت ابوابها
للحالمين الجدد ولافكارهم الواعده
حضروا ليواجهوا لجنه تحكيم تضم امهر
الحكام كلا في مشابه العضوين الدائمين
البروفيسور فؤاد مراد السيده عائشه
لمضاحكه وحكم المتخصص انضم اليهم في كل من
المحاور الثلاثه
اختراعات غريبه نماذج عجيبه
[موسيقى]
م رفضها قبل الاختبار
يعني لازم اخذ اقتراحه
لم يتقبلوا الرفض بعد
والضوء الاحمر لم يعني لهم شيئا
اما اللجنه فبحثت عن الافضل
فقط اعطي الضوء الاخضر ومعه فرصه التاهل
الى المرحله الثانيه
مشتركا سيواجهون لجنه التحكيم من جديد
اليوم موعد المواجهه الحسم
المبتكرون في وجه الحكام انه المجلس
العلمي الى المبنى الرئيسي لمؤسسه قطر حضر
الحكام الخمسه لاختيار تسعه مشتركين لخوض
مغامره الموسم الثامن ضغط وتوتر بين
المشتركين وقرارات مصيريه بين الحكام
الابتكارات
حياه تسعه مشتركين ستستقر في الدوحه
وهنا الاقامه هنا معمل الاحلام في واحه
العلوم والتكنولوجيا
استحدثت ثلاثه مربعات علميه جديده
ليستقبل كل منها ثلاثه مشتركين اختلفت
اجواء المربعات وتفاوتت احداثها
طه على هذا الموسم جو انساني عمل مع
المكفوفين
حل ان هو يقدر يقرا كتب فدي حاجه عظيمه
جدا جهد مع المتوحدين
واحد عنده عالم خاص به
كل الاطفال المتوحدين
شهد الفريق الاخضر اجواء عائليه مع يازي
وطفلتها
[موسيقى]
اما الازرق
فاجواء الصداقه طغت عليه بوجود احمد
الخباط
واساليبه الفكاهيه
اما الاصفر
الرياح المشاكل الدراميه هبت فيه
لتنتقل وتطالب كل المربعات
تسعه ابتكارات متنوعه لم يجمع بينها الا
مشاكل تقنيه
وتجارب دقيقه الوقت يمر والضغط يستهد
سيصود حتى النهايه
لاول مره اكتملت الابتكارات التسعه بالشكل
التصميمي والمضمون الهندسي
سنين مقتنع بفكرته قدك انت
[موسيقى]
في ختام هذه المرحله اطاحت العاصفه
الهندسيه بثلاثه مشاريع لتبقي على سته
ابتكارات تاهلت الى مرحله تقييم الاسواق
في هذه المرحله اكتسب المشتركون خبره
تجاريه واسعه بحثوا فيها عن مستهلكين
معاييرهم عاليه ولا يرضون الا بالافضل
صدمه الخساره شهدها
مشترك قبل خطوات من النهائي المنتظر
الليله موعد تخرج الجيل الثامن من النجوم
غسان سديم
عبد الرحيم
وصلوا بفكره خاضوا معارك الهندسه واجهوا
تحديات التصميم مالو رضا المستهلكين
واليوم هم بجداره رواد جيل ثامن ترعاه
مؤسسه قطر مودفيكس
ابتكارات استحق التاهلها بشداره مبتكريها
والليله مبتكر عربي واحد سيتوج نجما ثامنا
على عرش نجوم
[موسيقى]
نرحب باعضاء لجنه التحكيم الموقره اليوم
المهمه عليهم راح تكون مهمه لربما تكون
الصعبه والاخيره بالنسبه لهم جميعا
لاختيار وتحديد المراكز الاول والثاني
والثالث والرابع عوده الى الحاضر وما
يخفيه من مفاجات واولها مع رساله
بالعرب نجم نال شعبيه كبيره عربيه لا حدود
لها من هو انه الدكتور فاروق الباسل
لقد اثبت تاريخ البشريه
ان ازدهار العلم والمعرفه لا يعرف الحدود
ويمكن ان يتم في اي مكان بالعالم
المثل الحي لذلك ان بيننا اليوم نخبه
متميزه من الشباب العربي تعمل جاهده لرفعه
اوطاننا وازدهار مجتمعاتنا لذلك فانا فخور
بهم جميعا وكذلك من شارك معنا في الماضي
ودموع المشاهدين في العالم العربي باكمله
وخاصه الشباب
لقد اثبت نجوم العلوم ان التقدم العلمي
والازدهار التكنولوجي
يتم بالفكر الثاقب والعمل الدؤوب
لذلك فاني اقول ان المستقبل بيدنا
ويمكن ان نتقدم بفكرنا
وفقهم الله وسدد خطاكم جميعا
اللهم امين واحنا كذلك نتمنى لهم جميع عن
كل التوفيق هذه اكيد دعوه من دكتور فاروق
الباز دعوه علميه مفتوحه للعمل والمعرفه
والمشاركه في برنامج نجوم العلوم برنامج
نجوم العلوم اثار الكثير من التعليقات
والاسئله من بين جميع الحكام دكتور فؤاد
مراد يمكن اكثر الاشخاص الذي اثار الكثير
من التساؤلات من هنا ياتي السؤال لكن ابي
اخذ استعدادك جاهز للسؤال الدكتور فؤاد
انا جاهز يقال لا يعجبك العجب ولا صيام في
رجب كثير وصفوك بالقساوه المبالغ فيها هل
من مبرر لهذا التعامل خلينا نقول دكتور
انا ماني متفاجئ بالسؤال
وثاني شيء هذا التعليق انا افتخر فيه لانه
نحن اليوم بالعالم العربي
الشباب والصبايا العرب انه يعرفوا حالهم
وين عايشين بسنه 2016 التقدم العلمي
والمنتجات التكنولوجيه اللي صارت باخر
سنتين بالعالم اكثر من اللي صار بالعالم
باخر 20 سنه العالم يتقدم بخطوات سريعه
جدا ولا مكان الا للتميز العلمي والابتكار
ببرنامج الجمل العلوم انا مصر شخصيا انه
نكون قاسيين تنبتكر سويه بتميز نحن نجوم
والضغط هو هدفه ايجابي لكي نجد الافضل
دكتور
دبلوماسي حتى في اجاباتك هو رائع انا عن
نفسي صراحه اشكرك على هذه الاجابه شكرا
شكرا لك دكتور فؤاد مراد مبدعون الاربعه
يحضرون انفسهم لتوجيه رساله اخيره لجميع
اعضاء لجنه التحكيم اما الان فاصل نتواصل
فيه معاكم عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
تويتر وانستجرام خليكم معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا معنا مشاهدينا الكرام في
نهايه الموسم الثامن من نجوم العلوم على
الام بي سي 4 ترك برنامج نجوم العلوم اثره
لدى الشباب العربي ومحبي العلوم وهذا
بالتحديد ما يريد متابعوه البرنامج معرفته
من السيده عائشه المضحكه السيده عائشه
حياك الله سؤال يطرح نفسه الان ايش
الانطباع للترك فيش برنامج هجوم العلوم
كشخص متابع له فيما مضى واليوم انت عضو في
لجنه التحكيم شاركتي على النهايه هل هناك
بعض ذكريات معينه اللي ما زالت راسخه في
بالك من الموسم الثامن
وجودي فالبرنامج تعلمت وايد اشياء من
الحكام اللي موجودين معانا دكتور فؤاد
والباقي وفي نفس الوقت تعلمت من المبتكرين
اللي موجودين
هي اهوى طموح لكن في نفس الوقت يبي له وقت
بلا صبر وايد اشياء عشان يوصل للهدف اللي
هو يبي يوصل لك وبالنسبه لك قطريه انا جدا
فخوره ان برنامج نفس برنامج نجوم العلوم
موجود من قطر من مؤسسه قطر لدعم المبتكرين
في الدول العربيه شكرا للسيده عائشه عبد
الرحيم بريس يقف على منصه النجوميه
استعدادا لتوجيه رساله اخيره لعلها تميل
الدفه لصالحه كانت صامت الدائم فصارى يغرد
كان خجولا فصارى جريئا برنامج هجوم العلوم
غيرت تماما كما غير واقع الاطفال
المتوحدين طريقه البدايه مع عبد الرحيم
رئيس
[موسيقى]
في ارض الجزائر طيبه واصاله
في شيوخها قدوه وفي اطفالها رجاء
في جدرانها حنين حضارات نسجت تاريخا مشيئا
في هذه الارض ولد عبد الرحيم بوريس في
مدينه عريقه اسمها تلمسان
من هذه المدينه في غرب الجزائر تلمسان في
كل مكان قدمي الى ولي فيه ذكرى ذكريات
[موسيقى]
انا كنت نشتغل ميكانيكي عبد الرحيم كان
يحب يخدم معي بزاف
كان ابني وصديقي في نفس الوقت كنت افتخر
كثير واسعد لما اسمع الناس يتكلموا على
والدي على انه بارع وانه ذكي في ميدان
عمله في الميكانيك كنت لما اذهب مع اساله
على كل صغيره وكبيره هذه الحاجه علاش هكذا
وهذه علاش هكذا وهذه كيفاش تعمل وهذه
ابنائهم الصوره على على الاباء هذا الاساس
عن والده ورث الاحتراف وانطلق في مشوار
علمي طموح كان ثمرته شهاده الدكتوراه في
هندسه الاتصالات منذ بدايه تعلم ابجديات
البحث العلمي بدات اشتغل على مشاريع
الخاصه بدويه الاحتياجات الخاصه واذا
بتلقى مكالمه من امراه قالت لي انا ام
لطفل متوحد فضلا منك ان تفكر فينا احنا
ايضا احنا نعاني الويلات
[موسيقى]
اي ام واب عندهم طفل توحدي هي معاناه
يوميه ادق التفاصيل هي بالنسبه لنا صعوبه
ادق التفاصيل
انا عشت معاهم وصراحه كان شيء مؤثر جدا
صادروا من العلم انه يوجد حل لهذه الاطفال
التوحد مشكله حلها كان في القميص الذكي
التي ابتكره عبد الرحيم في نجوم العلوم
لمساعده الاهل في مراقبه اطفالهم
المتوحدين
هو مشروع موجه للعائلات انا من مدينه
لايرانا في العائله تمجيد كبير
العائله هي الاساس كنا متاحدين كامل
العائله هي البيئه هي المحيط الذي يساعد
اي مبدع اي مخترع ان يصل الى هدفه اي شيء
نوصف به ايجابيا فهو احنا اخذينه من
العائله
[موسيقى]
شفت الخير في عبد الرحيم
فرحانه
وعارفه باللي يزيد يكمل ويوصل
ندعي له بالنجاح والصحه
والذريه الصالحه ان شاء الله
البيئه التي انا نشات فيها هيئه علميه
محضر العلم اول اولويه عندهم هدفي امثل
بلدي وامثل مستمعي احسن تمثيل لما وصلت
للفاينل وحسيت نفسي فاينل رحت في عالم اخر
مرت عليه 3 ايام وانا مش مصدق انا في
الفايل صح احنا العائلات نتاوعنا اصحابنا
كاع التلمسانين وكاع معك
انا مدارس اسبوع صوتهم انتم جمهور العلوم
اللي مبدعكم المفضل الاف المتابعين شاركوا
في التصويت عبر الانترنت الجمهور قال
كلمته وبقي تصويت لجنه التحكيم ويبدو ان
عبد الرحيم جاهز لاقناع اللجنه بانه يستحق
[موسيقى]
هو اسم على مسمى هو ثمره الكثير من
التضحيات والجهد ولمعرفه المزيد على الغده
الذي يفيد عائلات اطفال التوحد اليكم
التقرير التالي
مع تفشي عوارض التوحد عند الاطفال خاضع
بالرحيم الاجتماعي من الجزائر
عالما بعيدا عن التكنولوجيا بيعيش معاناه
الاهل والاطفال ويسخر ذكاء اصطناعيا في
سبيل تحرير الطفل المتوحد من الرقابه
الدائمه ويسمح له بالاندماج في الحياه
الاجتماعيه من خلال قميص ذكي يشخص حالته
انيا
وينبه الاهل عن بعد مع توصيات طبيه مدموجه
بمعالجات ضوئيه وميكانيكيه فوريه
تضطرب تبعا للظروف والحاله الطبيه
لا يترك طفلا يتوحد في مجتمعه
[موسيقى]
هو اكثر المشاريع في التحديات فقد جمعت
فيه بين الهندسه والطب وعلم النفس وفاء
لعائلات اطفال التوحد جاء عن دائما ابدع
لكي احول الفكره الى منتج حقيقي فعال وهذا
بفضل دعم مؤسسه قطر عائلات التوحد حزنهم
يحزنني وسعادتهم تصعدني وابشرهم ان وندر
كيت جاهز يكون نجما جديدا يجلب لهم
السعاده صوتوا فانه مشروع تكنولوجي
وانساني بامتياز
والله العظيم لما الان شفت
البيشوك انا متاكد باللي يدق
من المفرح انا نشوف احد المخترعين يركز
جهوده للفائده مصابين بالتوحد
عبد الرحيم انه شو ما يصير هو فايز بينبسط
لانه عمل اشتغل وتعب ووصف وهيدا المهم
يعني جهاز ما في مثله في السوق فان شاء
الله ان شاء الله بنتمنى له التوفيق
بغض النظر عن النتائج الرحله الحقيقيه
ستبدا بعد البرنامج مباشره
[موسيقى]
عبد الرحيم اذا هو نجم النجوم اما غسان
يوسف من البحرين فقد دفعته الرياضه الى
دخول معترك العلم اعتاد على المواجهه
الجسديه وهنا تعرف على مواجهه من نوع اخر
فابدع فيها واثبت ان جسمه السليم يحمل
العقل السليم فمن هو غسل
[موسيقى]
بقعه في الخليج العربي مزجت بين حداثه
الغرب واصاله الش
رق بلد صغير انتج عقولا كبيره اسمه مثنى
لكلمه بحر بحر وسعه وسع امانه
في البحرين ولد شاب طموح اسمه غسان
ول
ديه هذه البدله هي غيرتها
كل ثيابه طلعتهم الا لباس موجودين عندي
محتفظه فيهم
غسان مو صغير كنا نخاف عليه كان اول واحد
وتعرف فرحتنا به واخاف عليه حتى من الهوى
فذكر طفولتي ان انا كنت خجول احس بواحده
في الحي اللي انا ساكن فيه
مضروب
في يوم من الايام انا رجعت البيت شافتني
الوالده انا زعلان قالت لي من باكر بتروح
بتلعب
بدله مجرد ما تلبسها تحس بالنظام انت مع
الوقت قاعد تكتشف قدراتك اللي انت اصلا ما
كنت تعرف انه تقدر تسويها في يوم من
الايام
[موسيقى]
واحتراف زرعت العناده وعشق الانتصار في
شخصيه غسان
وايد أبي اوصل اكون افضل من غيري اكون من
غيري اسرع من غيري وجبت بطوله المملكه
مرتين كان في الاضواء والاثاره والناس
اللي تشجعك يعني كان شيء جميل لكن كان في
مشكله
ما كان في التكنولوجيا اللي تارخ لك من
انت كرياضيين مجرد ما تخلص مسيرتنا بعد
سنه سنتين
من هني
هو اول ابتكار يحفظ بيانات اللاعبين
وانجازاتهم ابتكار ولد في نجوم من شغف
غسان بالرياضه والتكنولوجيا
اليوم احب اقدم لكم احد ابطالنا السابقين
اللاعب غسان يقدم احد الاختراعات الافضل
راح تكون في الفتره المقبله
[موسيقى]
في يوم من الايام غسان كان في عمر الشباب
طموحه كبر مع تقدمه للبطولات وخبرته في
الملعب احنا نقول لغسان خليك ماضي في هذا
المشروع وكلنا ان شاء الله واقفين خلفك ان
شاء الله
[موسيقى]
اليوم انا صرت اب وعندي طفل عمره سنه
واربع شهور
شيء انا مريت فيه انا اتمنى انه ما يمر
فيه فلازم اقوي شخصيته من الحين كله ابغي
انه يكون قادر يتاقلم مع المحيط البدله
اللي قاعد اعطيها اياه اليوم
تمثل لطريقه حياه
يقف بثقه فوق منصه النجوميه وكان القوه
الجسديه ستحمله الى فضائل العلوم والليله
يريد عبر رساله صغيره توجيه ضربه قاضيه
للحصول على اللقب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لما جيت من البحرين الى نجوم العلوم تركت
اهلي وشغلي والتزاماتي في سبيل تحقيق
الحلم انا لاعب رياضي وعواجب وايد مشاكل
في رياضتك ليش ما انا اوجد حل مثالي لفنون
القتاليه علشان نعرف مع بعض شنو هو خلنا
نشوف التقرير التالي
تقصر القدره البشريه عن تصنيف نوعيه
الضربه تبعا لزاويه النظر غسان لاعب من
البحرين
قام بتوظيف عيون اصطناعيه للاحاطه بسرعه
بكل الزوايا داعمه بدقتها التحكيم العادل
كما توثق الاداء الرياضي في ذاكره عميقه
ودقيقه
لتثبت بالبرهان كفاءه اللاعب وتصنيفه
توثيق دائم وتحكيم عادل
[موسيقى]
التايكوان
في عام 2016 احرز العرب ثلاث ميداليات
اولمبيه عدد صغير صح انا مو بس ابغي ارفع
من مستوى اللاعبين انما انا ابغي اسيطر
على اولمبياد 2020 فما فوق تيكوان راح
نخلي البلاد العربيه مركز يتوافق اليه
اللاعبون علشان يرفعون المستواهم تصويتم
الى اليوم راح نخلي الحلم العربي حقيقه
كارو رائع جدا ومفيد الجميع رياضيه
تايكوندو وفي المستقبل اكيد لجميع
الرياضيين
[موسيقى]
الله
جدا متحمس اني اشوف نتيجه النهائي وان شاء
الله الاختراع الرياضي هو اللي يحصل على
المركز الاول
[تصفيق]
سمعنا رسالتين من عبد الرحيم ومن غسان
وباقي ثلاثه سديم سباق وانتم ايضا والان
هي فرصتكم للاشتراك في نجوم العلوم كباب
التسجيل في الموسم التاسع مفتوح عبر
الموقع الالكتروني
فاصل ونرجع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا معنا في نهائي الموسم
الثامن من نجوم العلوم على شاشه الام بي
سي 4 الليله ليله الرسائل المبدعون العرب
كثر يكفي ان نبحث عنهم انتم استخدمتم سوار
جبون لتتبع اللياقه البدنيه ونحن استقبلنا
صاحب فكره السوار اليكم الرساله التي
وجهها الكسندر عسيل
لما يجي بيزنس
[موسيقى]
ما هي المجالات العلميه المستقبليه التي
تعتقد ان هناك فيها نقص ممكن للشباب العرب
انهم يغطون هذا النقص فيه
المكان
[موسيقى]
شكرا للسيد
نواصل الرسائل الليله مع الاردني سديم
قديسات شارك في تصفيات الجوله الاولى منذ
عامين فرفضت اللجنه اقتراحا لم يقبل الفشل
حول مره ثانيه وفي قلبه اصرار نابع من
شعور الواجب بمساعده الاخرين ووصل الى
النهائي هذه المره نتعرف سويا الى سديم
قديسات في هذا التفريق
[موسيقى]
موطنه يمزج بين القديم والحديث
طبيعته قاسيه
عنيده كصلابه اهدافه
منازله واسعه
ضواحيه كبيره
كبره طموحه واسعه احلامه
[موسيقى]
هذا سديم اقليسات ابن جرش والبتراء موطن
العرب الانباط
[موسيقى]
كان عندي هدف انه اولادي يطلعوا افضل مني
بكثير
هو اصغر ولادي بس هو يختلف عنك كلياتها ان
يتحدى ذاته من هو صغير
[موسيقى]
كنت دائما بدي اياه يكون الافضل فكنت ما
اشعر انه هو مميز
كنت واعدته
انه يوم التخرج اكيد بدي اجي فقلت له خلص
وعد بس تخرج انا جاي ظروفي ما ساعدتني
اطلع فبكيت
وافتخر فيك بس لا تحكونا
انا بحس بافتخار انه عندي ابن زي سدين هو
بطبيعته بحب المساعده الناس بحب التطوع
كثير
سديم شغوف بالعمل التطوعي
اطفال السرطان السر قلبه وعقله واحنا
الاشياء اللي كنت كثير قريبه على قلبي
اطول عليها دايما اللي هو مركز الحسين
للسرطان
[موسيقى]
في بيبي كان واقف على امراهى من الكيمي
راح شعره فكان ماسك ماركر وعم بلون شعر
لحاله بهداك الوقت انا خلاص اخدت عهد بس
اكبر لازم اعمل اشي تؤيد على كل الناس
اللي بالمرضى بهذه السرطان
حسم سديم اهدافه
وانتقل الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لدراسه الطب
في
كل اخذتها من الاردن وطبقتها هون عملي
شريحه من مرضى السرطان
من ضمن
فكره ولدت في باريس ديم منذ اربع سنوات
لتبصر النور اخيرا في نجوم العلوم
[موسيقى]
المعروف بعناده وبثقته المطلقه بنفسه باقي
على اصراره وهو مقتنع تماما بان اللقب له
لان الفرصه الاخيره لاقناع لجنه التحكيم
وها هو يقف على منصه النجوميه فماذا في
جعبه سديم
[تصفيق]
السلام عليكم
اليوم راح يتحدد مصير ثلاث شهور من حلم
ابطاله ومحاربين السرطان فتى قبل اربع
سنين خلينا نشوف جنابك
وراء الطب الشافي اعمال مخبريه دقيقه
ومضنيه لكوادر بشريه كفوءه ومجهوله
تعتمد على مهنيتها وجهدها في فحوصات
ضروريه تحاكي الحياه
او عدمها
سديم المثابر من الاردن
انتفض وسخر الدق في تكرار المهام لدى
الروبوت
ليوفر الوقت والجهد البشري لمهام اكثر
راحه وذكاء
المحطه الاليه لسديم تفحص جينيا عينات دم
متعدده في وقت قياسي وبنتيجه موثوقه
لا ندام في العجله
[موسيقى]
وفي التاني
[تصفيق]
اجيت على البرنامج
يحقق حلم اوروبا امريكا ما قدروا يامنوني
اللي امنتلي اياه مؤسسه القدر من خلال
برنامج هجوم العلوم احنا وحمد وسيدرا
وصلنا لنتيجه فقط توقعاتنا اليوم بدايه
لثوره في عالم الفحوصات الجينيه ونساعد كل
المحاربين السرطان شكرا
سديم قال احسن
واتمنى النجاح ان شاء الله نجاح نجاح باهر
في ايصال الفكره وكذلك ايصال الاموشن شيء
جبار الصراحه شيء جبار انه يوصل لان هو
لوقا صعوبات وايد في المختبر اختراع
وعجبني بالاخص انه يمس حاجه فيه انا عمي
رحمه الله عليه توفر بالسرطان
من السرطان السنه فاول ما سمعت انه في حدا
عم يعمل ابتكار بخصوص السرطان انا اهتميت
انه ادعم هالشخص باختراع ممتاز يلا يا
سديم شد حيلك انت نشمي وبتستاهل كل خير
فعلا الابداعي يتطلب نشاط غير عادي جيمس
انا عندي سؤال يخص وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي عندك انت بالتحديد على صفحه
الفيسبوك عندك على سبيل المثال عندك الاف
المتابعين وشويه لايكات نشاطك على
السوشيال ميديا هل فعلا موجود ايضا على في
حياتك العمليه حياتك الشخصيه في مختلف
جوانب حياتك ايضا
مزحه معك لك مثل ما ذكرتك مكانه خاص عندي
انا بالتحديد فاحب فاحب مداعبتك شكرا
لجيمس لحظه الحسم اقتربت ولجنه التحكيم
بانتظار اللبنانيه
للتعرف اولا على مسيرته للوصول الى اختراع
جاء من حب العملي والاراده الصلبه
[موسيقى]
بلده صغير المساحه كبير الانجازات متعدد
الحضارات كتعدد مواهب ابنائه اصاله شعبه
مثال لتشبث الارز بارضه
رائد منذ القدم في العلم والاعمال يمد
البحر المتوسط بامواج من الاجيال الصاعده
من ابناء لبنان
[موسيقى]
هذا المكان هو محل معنزات خلق في اسمه
بهندسه الميكانيك خلق هون
يمكن في 11 و12 سنه تاثرت ببين لان اصلا
هي مهنتهي بالميك والهيدروليكس
[موسيقى]
من هو وصغير لاحظ على الشغلات انه احنا
بالميك يعني نعرف هاي موجوده هو يلاحظ انه
هاي ليش موجوده هون
[موسيقى]
الله يرحمه كان لهذا الصبي يخوف هذا الصبي
رسول مش رسول
اكيد
بشغف كبير بالميك وبخبره الموروثه عن
والده حاز سيفاك على شهاده في هندسه
الميكانيك وماجستير في الميكاترونكس من
الجامعه الامريكيه في بيروت برع فيها
ليصبح معلما ناجحا في كليته
عم نشتغل على روبوت صغير كنا عايزين بارتس
اولفنا كتير في حدا اجا قال لي ليه ما
بتعملها
[موسيقى]
بعدين
من ورا خبرتي لعمل
موديفيكس ابتكار ولد في نجوم العلوم نتيجه
دراسه وخبره ليحدث ثوره بتوفير الوقت
وكفاءه الانتاج في الطباعه الثلاثيه
الابعاد
انا اليوم عم بشتغل بسبايسي اسمه
[موسيقى]
انا شخصيا بستعمل كتير بشغله كل البروتات
وبقشع قديش قيمتها
مشاكل بالقصص اللي هو عم بحلها
مشروع سباق مشروع كتير ناجح ونتملينه
الناجح من بيروت نقول له
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من نهار اللي بلشت فيه جامعه لليوم ما في
نهار وعيت مبسوط انه عندي شغل يعني الشغله
اكثر شي بحبه بحياتي
شغله معك لا اليوم ما في شغل اليوم شغل لا
لا بتاخذ الروبوت وبترجع عبيروت
هي الباص
هي كل
شي
صراحه انا تخرج اولادي كان اسعد نهار لالي
كان كل حلمي اسعد
[موسيقى]
لما يعني هلا هو عنده مشروع براسه بتمنى
انه يقدر يحقق هالمشروع لانه عن جد
بيستاهلها قد ما لانه قد ما بحب شغله
شغوف بالعمل ولا يحب الكلام وخاصه عن نفسه
ربما الكلام عدوه ازداد حراكه في الاونه
الاخيره فكثر الحديث عنه في الاعلام دعما
له وما يريده فعلا سباق هو تغيير الثوابت
فالث انه وصل الى المربع النهائي والمتغير
هو اقناع اللجنه بانه يستحق ان يكون على
راس القمه
[تصفيق]
الابتكار موديفيكس انسجام بين الهندسه
الميكانيكيه والالكترونكس والبرمجه خلينا
نشوف كيف
سباك من لبنان مهندس موهوب تبنى طابعه
ثلاثيه الابعاد من السوق
طور فيها وصنع مجسمات كان من المستحيل
تنفيذها في الماضي القريب وذلك بفضل زياده
حركيه على الطاوله الثابته
واضافه الرشاقه على الراس الموسع
مستغنيا بذلك عن طباعه اضافات لا جدوى
منها
مصرا الوقت والمواد المهجوره
لا شيء مستحيل على طابعه مودفيكس
[موسيقى]
طباعه ثلاثيه الابعاد هي ثوره بحد ذاته
كبرى عم تتنافس على تطوير هيدي
التكنولوجيا انا سيف شاب من لبنان عم
بتحنى الواقع عم بشتغل على تطوير
التكنولوجيا لنوصلها لكل مكتب وكل بيت
تسويتكم اليوم ومساهمه كبرى بالثوره
الصناعيه الثالثه
مع الطباعه ثلاثه الابعاد نقدر اخيرا
نراضي العالم ان احنا عندنا اختراعات
بنفسنا وعلشان كده انا اسميه الاختراع
للمخترعين واعتقد انه لو انا عندي اياه
الحين
خاصه في الاستوديو
كانجنير وكايديه اتوقع سباق
المنتجه راح يسوي ثوره جديده في عالم
تصنيع النماذج وهاي الليله كتير اثبت لسيف
انه ان شاء الله راح يكون من الرابحين
وبظن رح ياخد الاول ان شاء الله
[تصفيق]
انتهت ليله الرسائل وحان وقت عمل اعضاء
لجنه التحكيم اما انتم فعملكم لم ينتهي
بعد استفيدوا من الفاصل زياره دوت كوم
للتسجيل والاشتراك في الموسم التاسع من
نجوم العلوم خلكم معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم مجددا مشاهدينا الكرام في
اخر لحظات نهائي الموسم الثامن هجوم
العلوم واهلا وسهلا ايضا بالمبدعين
والخبراء وايضا المشاركين السابقين في
المواسم السابقه لبرنامج نجوم
الجميع هنا لمتابعه تصويت اللجنه القرار
النهائي والحاسم بين ايدي اعضاء لجنه
التحكيم الموقره للتذكير 50% من العلامه
تحددها هذه اللجنه اما الخمسين بالمئه
الباقيه فيحددها تصويت الجمهور ساعه الحسم
دقه اعضاء لجنه التحكيم الموقره ندعوكم
الى المهمه الاصعب بالنسبه لكم في هذا
الموسم
وهي تصويت لهؤلاء الاربعه واختيار نجم
الموسم الثامن من برنامج نجوم العلوم
تفضلوا بالتصويت
[موسيقى]
شكرا لاعضاء لجنه التحكيم الان اذا
النتيجه حسمت صار عندنا خمسين بالمئه من
تصويت الجمهور وكملتها ايضا الشق الثاني
خمسين بالمئه تصويت اعضاء لجنه التحكيم
انا عارف ان قلوبكم تخفق بشده وانا اعرف
انك كلكم تتمنون الحصول على لقب الموسم
الثامن من برنامج نجوم العلوم ولكن هناك
فائز واحد بس هو اللي راح يحصل على اللقب
الان انا راح اعلن عن نتيجه المتعلقه
بتصويت اعضاء لجنه التحكيم وهذا ما يعني
ان هذه هي النتيجه النهائيه لاني اذكر ان
في خمسين بالمئه راح تضاف عليها ايضا
لاكمال النتيجه ومعرفه من هو الفائز
بالموسم الثامن من برنامج نجوم العلوم
اعضاء لجنه التحكيم قرروا ان يكون
صاحب المركز الاول في الخمسين بالمئه
الاولى فقط
سباق عند صاحب المركز الاول حسب تصويت
اعضاء لجنه التحكيم
ولكن
الذي حصل على المركز الاول كان نسبته من
الجميع سته وثلاثين فاصله ثمانيه الثاني
واحد وثلاثين الثالث 23 الرابع ثمانيه
بالمئه من مجمل النتيجه نقول مبروك
مبروك
من الاردن
[موسيقى]
في المركز الثاني عبد الرحيم برويس من
الجزائر
بالمركز الثالث صفات من لبنان
وفي المركز الرابع غسان يوسف من البحرين
الف الف مبروك وصلنا الى نهايه هذه الحلقه
ونهايه الموسم الثامن من برنامج نجوم
العلوم اتمنى التوفيق لكل المشتركين
مشاهدينا الكرام نذكركم بالاشتراك في
الموسم التاسع لبرنامج نجوم العلوم عبر
والان مثل ما على الحب التقينا على الود
دايما نلتقي تصبحون على الف خير
[موسيقى]